actor Alec Baldwin will be charged with
negligent manslaughter in the shooting
death of cinematographer Helena Hutchins
on a film set in New Mexico in 2021.
he's also facing charges as a producer
because he should have known that the
conditions on that set were unsafe
Hannah Gutierrez read the armorer on the
set of the low-budget Western rust will
also be charged with the same offense in
film terminology the armorer is the
person responsible for the safety of all
weapons on a filming location
assistant director Dave Halls who
actually handed Baldwin the gun that
killed Hutchins has pleaded guilty to
negligent use of a deadly weapon
the charges follow a 15-month long
investigation Baldwin has publicly
claimed he was told the gun was cold or
not armed with lethal rounds and that he
never pulled the trigger saying instead
the weapon somehow malfunctioned however
an FBI analysis of the 45 caliber Colt
revolver determined it could not have
been discharged without pulling the
trigger prosecutors say the evidence
clearly shows a pattern of criminal
disregard for safety on the rust set
near Santa Fe really everything for the
armorer and Alec Baldwin come down to
criminal negligence and what they end a
determination that they were not acting
with reasonable care they were being
criminally negligent which means they
were grossly negligent in their action
Baldwin's attorney Luke Nicos denounced
the charges saying this decision
distorts Helena Hutchins tragic death
and represents a terrible miscarriage of
Justice photos taken after the shooting
showed Baldwin apparently distraught
mysteries in the case remain especially
how a live bullet came to be mixed in
with dummy rounds on the set and how
that bullet was loaded into the gun that
was then handed to Baldwin investigators
found an additional five live rounds at
the location Baldwin reached a financial
settlement with the Hutchins family last
year for an undisclosed amount of money
if convicted he could face five years in
prison Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los
Angeles relax